sivanna is with us in Maryland hey
Savannah how are you I'm well Dave how
are you great how can we help
don't go I have to be on with you and
Rachel so I am calling today because I
am in Financial Peace University and I'm
also on baby step two but I have three
hundred and sixty-three thousand dollars
worth of debt and I'm just wondering how
to stay motivated while I'm paying this
off well it's a lot of debt girl that
include red is that include your house
or is that is that other does not
include well you could say it's almost
the house I have loans which are you a
doctor or a lawyer
neither what is your degree I didn't
know that I didn't know what I wanted to
be when I grew up so I am actually a
nurse and I did not even pay to go to
nursing school I pay to get my master's
degree in nursing but to actually go to
nursing school I do not even pay okay so
you have a Masters in nursing I do what
do you make 120 okay that's good how's
that okay so if you live home if you
live on beans and rice rice and beans
how quick do you pay off 300 if you pay
60 a year it's five years right 300
divided by 60 is five right pay fifty a
year at six years pay seventy a year
it's four years and some change that
leaves you 50,000 live on hmm okay see
the math okay I see it you know let me
tell you our taxes a hundred and twenty
and you take seventy out your own beans
and rice well I got a and well I
actually have another full-time job I'm
working two jobs oh so what's your total
income so the total is probably is 190
oh look at you it gets better a better
okay okay well let me just let me give
you a couple numbers to kind of help
what gives me hope okay
the average household income in America
household income and sometimes that's
two people working is fifty nine
thousand dollars let's call it sixty
okay okay if you lived on the average
household income with 190 coming in that
would leave you 130 minus taxes right
that's a hundred a year you're done in
three years ain't gonna be fun I what
I'm the proscription I'm giving you miss
nurse is gonna hurt this is physical
therapy after the knee surgery okay okay
now okay you gonna have no freaking life
you've been Diddy bopping along making a
couple of hundred a year making no
progress I'm getting ready changed your
life and it ain't gonna be fun but it's
gonna get you out of debt well that's
what I want to do I want to get out of
debt yeah I mean you're gonna have to
live like no one else so later you can
live and give like no one else you're
single I'm married actually okay what's
he make but my husband is not he makes
ninety oh my god but I'm getting better
every man but he's not like into the
baby sets yet although he has no debt
I've convinced him I just talking so
he's paid off two cars he's paid off all
those credit cards and he actually gave
me $20,000 for Valentine's Day so I paid
off a lot of things okay I want the two
of you to combine your finances and your
freaking $300,000 household income and I
want you to get your little bitty
$300,000 where the debt paid off in two
and a half years and I want you to
combine your goals combine your incomes
you make more he makes I guess he's not
going to financial University with you
is he are you going are you enough for
you you want you
yeah yeah he needs to go with you no
he's not he's going with you
he's go with you it's marriage
counseling gonna change your life
you guys got plenty of money you just
been wandering around without a game
plan and you need to bear down on this
and you can do it then the math is more
convincing than you are you got to get
convinced and you're still not sure
inhabit and I'm sitting there going a
hundred thousand a year for three years
you're done or oh wait a minute my
husband makes a hundred oh my gosh
that's two hundred a year yeah let's get
another job and then why yeah this is
getting better by the minute you know I
mean
Wow keep talking to her we're gonna have
a whole new story I may get some money
before this is over
this is great you're doing so good all
you got to start believing and be
willing to pay a price and write that
down and the two of you buckle down lock
arms for better for worse for richer for
poorer in sickness and in health all my
worldly goods I pledge unto you that's
what the old marriage vows said and
we'll say that anymore they used to say
it and they should